everything happened incredibly lucky
very young and still there were probably
500 parts we didn't get easily so many
so many rejections that I mean it's a
helpful thing about having your best
friend do it too because you we used to
call it getting okay thanks like you go
into a room and you'd pour your heart
out for the for a casting director and a
director and they go like okay thanks
and you'd realize I didn't get the part
and all you really have is you know we'd
go home we lived together with his
little brother you know and and and we'd
just go sit there and how to go I got
okay thanks and uh sorry man the kind of
job interview where you also are like
pouring your heart out and crying too
you know
thanks that's fine are we good okay
because I'm sobbing yeah remembering
like the most dramatic moment in my life
I would say you know a stand-up comedy
you know going on stages you know making
sure that you you're ready and you know
you have audience sometimes you have
great shows sometimes you have lukewarm
shows so you got to go back to the club
really struggle or were you just like
pop bang right yeah I didn't really
struggle that much I was trying to find
something